hi good morning good morning hi we have with me or
great polyglot via friend gabriel who
is traveling the world is meeting
beautiful girls and speaking in japanese in
korean in all languages gabriel ok ok
always a pleasure to be on your
hannel don't want and i
's say  please tell me now who wants to go
or more is aware of this moment i
started to learn finnish
this andré's topic i am doing a
little polish my polish i
sometimes i have arrived at a2 in promise
is it is bad i understand i love it more maybe
because of what i speak russian i
think my face is not i got to b2 but
i also stopped practicing a bit
so bro it's worse so i decided
maybe then i'll try to improve
my polish a little who knows how to get one
have one e  I really like
the Polish one a lot and I also thought why not
pop a totally different language
which is the movie where you say
wow how many languages you speak and that one more or le
s here so let's see  r
portuguese in english c2 which is very
good which is good
good so i said i thought my english
especially is not almost the same cowardice
son of academy context i studied
here i went there i said so
i mean i think i can manage
express more confidently and even
elegantly in english what in portuguese
a question spanish is said the expression
in french in french saying print
i have read in a book or portuguese is
that if first instead of expressing
the dismissal words ymir would be a para
a lemon for a juice to squeeze but it's
just not an excuse so I think that
then for example French and German
I certainly reached at least p2 and
maybe in being one and a lot when in this
practice it will fall into my French
now ok  good because i've been practicing a
lot german i haven't been practicing it
so it must have fallen on stage but
italian and dutch i think i
also got to b2 but also the same
thing for you as a me  io rarely in
russian i also think i got to
b2 to send heroes too now i also
have to practice that all forgetting
all afrikaans and catalan i have a
very high level of understanding and then it
will drop from for example a little
romanian i think  that maybe I arrived maybe
some is one or less
is really good two then for example a
bit of a lot of languages at level a1 czech
slovak ukrainian even but if enoug
is ok and so japanese at most i hav
that one day i want to dedicate mysel
in the hill to learn but really didn't
speak much introductory korean vase and
several languages that i studied a little bit like
hat and that doesn't go very far for examp
e the play i think at most a too b
t i want i want to learn what clean
a lot of people here arabic also only
a little bit and that's it for me
hebrew hebrew rose and then it's
something worth learning just a
little
what it is yes it's ok if you speak badly it's
we married you speak it very well this is the one who will
go  I am the same well others around the house and
country that you speak there is one thing I
like a lot although those who don't speak
very well two questions two questions
first how do you keep
these languages because it's getting tired it's very diffi
ult I for example wanted to speak
major in portuguese at the moment i'm not
studying skin if i look good if i
would spend more time is the week
messi listening reading portuguese and
now he's found some podcast or
globe from brazil a lot
and now before our conversation he's been
listening to about  the economic situation
coronavirus if selection right I ask
everyone there bolsonaro very interesting
very interesting this is jonathan
for 12 weeks between the time to
study portuguese
and speak hey not better but it is not try to
choose what i can do
and well i will  keep on learning
new languages or I'm going to learn languages that you speak or le
s well but it's always a matter of time and
how do you go about discovering
new languages and  keep a
certain level in is ours will your
questions spectacular good first i
have i have been especially
recently dedicating myself a lot to the
workshop i have many students in
many countries many brazilians for
example learn english for more and
that means i have been dedicating myself a lot
as  teacher developing my courses
and everything else not even dedicating myself to, for
example, on youtube and I have many
interests pleasure that I love music
I love sculpting I love drawing so
I've been dedicating a little less
time to languages in general but still good
o for example I  I always try to
have a certain exposure to languages that I alr
ady speak relatively well what I've already said
ell for example I try to watch a vid
o huh Dutch sometimes I go to th
link and everything for example I could
I'm going to study a little bit of  a
destination that doesn't even have a very nice kid's dick
with her i make it go i forgot
her name and in dutch and then for
example too  it's russian i started to read a
little bit of pushkin's book he
has a lot of russian literature books
that i love and for example i
watch a lot of videos in french they
actually that you're going to do something
i mean i always try to have  a
minimum exposure for example so by
having some contact with the languages that I alrea
y speak relatively well and I try to do this
t least once a week for m
st languages it's one and it's no
for everyone because every day no cat I wo
ld be  possibl
if you think it is necessary to maintain a
proportion between the new language they are
learning and how others would go but that
already rises I don't know magno feels the
need to maintain that that's the
proportion between new languages and maint
nance maintenance maint
nance by  example I think it depends on my
goal right let's say it like this if you
have one let's say it like this I don't know if
I'm going to do it but I get really serious I
want to get the p1 promises by
exe  mple I don't think so I
would dedicate myself let's say that then I decide to
learn to be once a little bit
also then what I would do usually I
would dedicate eighty percent of my
language time to Polish and only 20 the
last one of them  one and up to
a certain level of progress at the beginning and
then maybe reversing from there dedicating myself
eighty percent in this deliciousness of
percent to the Polish so as not to lose and the
brand for example now that I really
don't have this goal we have launch
so specific of what I want  boost
Polish I want you to check out this language
I've been dedicating more or less
eighty percent to the review and
maintenance of the languages I speak to see i
I'm trying to progress because of cours
I think the process I'm learn
ng yet I didn't call him  only
and twenty percent new languages like Polis
and that didn't give only lives once not o
ly really so I started the basics in th
basics then concentrating myself enough langu
ges that I already  I speak and now we're going to
bake
and we're going to change the subject it's for
people who would not
and speak English very well not who want to
improve their birthday in English and
and you can give some advice
not some ideas it's because it's good
we speak  10 15 languages I don't want most
eople want to make
breakthrough audience it's not becau
e there many people who study in Engli
h the other and always have the impre
sion that they don't profess and t
is one you can say our health befor
is Brazilian  who have difficulties
with english want to improve their level in
english is it you as a brazilian is
brazilian or not brazilian brazilian
ok you are the first i think a lot
of what i am going to say will
exactly match your recommendations is
because exactly what basically what
I follow for example number one I
think exposure is essential and
especially text and audio that I
like to do for example penis
also at your level let's go  say if you
are at the very basic level maybe you will
find videos of or that audio and
text or video and text of small
conversations are often 2 or 3 minutes and
have a high level of exposure discuss
several times translation see a
vocabulary
and have a lot a lot a lot  people who like
to do it closed uai he has to be
talking at the same time until recording I saw it
later and also for example then if you
have a higher level you really have
exposure to quality material that
you like for example what
really matters can be  a little expensive it can
be even netflix.com series I don't know and
have a very high level disposition then it
can be like this maybe for those who have
the most intermediate to advanced level
we will be podcasts or even this audio the
sinditest 15 to 20 minutes and  really diving into
a language is very dedicated and
leaving his as it is this is the grammar
a little cold because there are a lot of people
get very narrow with grammar and I
think that for example  it's much more it's kind
of a lot of added value
is, for example, examples of
something than just listening to an
explanation at a time because I can speak
like that in the present perfect regret
that means I can explain the
grammatical structure or I can give you 30  example
that you are a lot more once i took the
complete sentences employing them the pleasure
or is it so danubia business a water block
that has a lot of examples used to
be through many many example if
you have to believe in the brain 10
likely the mass also the  important it
is important to pay attention for example
now we are saying not to me it is not
possible to speak in portuguese that i don't
speak it never makes a guy but you also have
to pay attention to what you are
saying for example i said niver as
in spanish for the time  listen or not it
's not level 1 level 2 level I learned
something good that we level this level and
I believe that the opportunity to speak is
very important to speak to a pa
what are the words passive vocabulary oh it's
so I'm going to open the
active vocabulary I don't want you too you are a coffin
our we are talking it will be
interesting to me this between what
you are saying i don't have also
pay attention to how you use the language
also an example was that conversation it's not
just loud also an example
and i think that's fantastic it's very
true and one thing also one we
taught me in other videos is that
unfortunately many brazilians are
simply afraid
to speak english even sometimes they are already
at a very bad level  or even two there but
still afraid because they are afraid of
making mistakes they are making they don't want to make
mistakes in front of others and this
unfortunately will only block it will only
delay the process because it means
why not make one have a friend via skype
trying to chat with a friend in English
even making mistakes and that's why it
reminds me, for example, of a
situation I had with one when I was
learning Italian  I met a
girl in the most I remember cristiano.com
without having a very nice girl and we
Italian was very very low too
and I mean for us to communicate it was
frustrating even
and I was trying I was there on google
play this is not a little in  little
logically it improved and I gained
that confidence then I arrived at the
Italian influence after a year I
don't know and I mean no I wasn't in
my comfort zone what was
on top was boring so that
means we call her trying to learn to
learn English  or trying to learn
Italian we both got beat up but
eventually poker fire got better and
made a difference kind of little by little
you weren't it's the case you have to keep going
good ok very well sorry it's not my
life for everything that everyone could
very good  it's always
and nothing science is like that it's
like that it's like that anyways anyways
anyway ok thank you very much a hug see you
later and so
and so